more than 200 people have reportedly
been killed in ethiopia in an attack in
the aromia region
witnesses say the victims belong to the
amhara ethnic group the aramo liberation
army has been blamed for the attack but
it says it is not involved but ethiopia
is an ethnically diverse nation but it's
experiencing widespread tensions with
hundreds of people killed in recent
years
much of the south and west is inhabited
by the aroma people who make up the
largest population group to the north is
the amhara region amhara communities are
ethiopia's second largest group
conflicts have largely been fueled by
groups demanding more land and power
with attempts to drive out those they
regard as outsiders
okay let's uh get more from the
independent journalist samuel guilichi
who joins us from addis ababa and sam
tell us more about this attacker 200
people have been killed so far
what well what we know so far is more
than 230 people have died that number is
expected to go much much higher this
morning the prime minister prime
minister abi ahmed tweeted saying his
priority our priority he said referring
to his government is to bring peace and
security but it's been a challenging few
years to
ethiopia and ethiopians
there was an attack last week in
gambella where a majority of the city
was overpowered by uh uh
or oromo liberation front which the
government has accused of being a
terrorist organizations in this
organizations when they're defeated uh
somewhere else uh they tend to react uh
in other parts of ethiopia as we've seen
yesterday this last weekend
which again
at least 230
amhara people of ethiopia were killed
but once again that number is uh
expected to go much higher and the
government is uh expected to uh react as
pressure to act uh is mounting right and
tell us more about the context of this
in the country experiencing you know
widespread ethnic tensions
yes nick as you mentioned uh ethiopia is
a diverse nation it has more than 90
different ethnic groups in this country
of 120 million people
some blame the previous government which
had ethnic federalism that was
implemented to empower minorities but
instead what it has really done to
ethiopians is
break the idea of citizenship
all of a sudden ethiopians are have
impressed
their ethnic background instead of their
citizenship everyone feels they're
either an amhara or romo or grage or
segre and so on
and again showing that
it hasn't really
reached
how it was intended and it has really
broken the system of citizenship
and we see it in many many parts of the
nation there was during the previous
government ethiopians were used to carry
an id that identified themselves not as
an ethiopian but
based on their ethnic backgrounds and
that really pushed many ethiopians from
um really going uh outside of their
ethnic
uh based society and that has really um
touched the core of what it means to be
an ethiopian in this country so i'm
going to chew on the context of that
attack in the aramia region sam thanks a
lot
thank